[музика]
5 років війни 6 ротацій пройшов Мар'ян
кошироке на Водяне авдіївку Дебальцеве
керував згодом вогневою підтримки
десятої гірсько-штурмової бригади ЗСУ А
ще поет блогер і вже як півтора роки
політик
[оплески]
[музика]
вони прийшли гуртом зі зброєю як зомбі
струни сказали гей Стрибай да льоху і на
стіл світили дітей на дорогу
відкопає А ось жінка твоя файна були з
нами нехай А ти пішов собі на пірі там
лопату взяв
і надо ходити і віддав команду жінці
тупою
безперервно подавали набої Не вмирай за
неї Ви за мир якщо порожнятами бізе Не
вмирай за нею спи за мить коли покличе
доля у
.»
ти кажеш що бачив світ а я бачив більш
за тебе те що весь бруд весь під це
тільки стежка по небу все буде чи тут Чи
десь бо доля вона строката а світ
міщається весь на дні рюкзака солдата
третя волна Я уже знал что я
смогу прийшов дочери
[музика]
з дитинства колискова співав не можу
згадати як
[музика]
я тримав небо А в небі велику зірку все
що мені треба щоб в тебе не було гірко у
двері стукає Різдво
вечір
ку у його стане таким
донечко то любов моя донечко
Зачекай завтра буде сонечко у Різдво
прилітають Янголи і все буде добре коли
я прийду тільки не знаю коли
дуже рано я спала як дитину
все марно не зумів не встигну А ти
мовчки підвівся зібрав своє речі і
підняв як дитину наче янгол на плечі Ми
пішли попід небом вздовж ріг та вокзалів
я казала не треба А ти ніс мене далі не
була я маленька і була як дитина ніста
неба тоненьке до моєї країни і казала не
можу це скінчилось все марно а теніс
мене далі ми злетіли під хмари
без культури нації нема без мови нації
немає
І це надважливі речі і пока поки поки
вони існують і ми будемо існувати
будь-які рани не закінчених війн
більшість завжди ветерани прапор Європи
зробили ті хто ти хочеш Сядь на нашу з
тобою могилу тільки твою вже декілька
років вкривають квіти а моя не відрита
але може бути відрита
це життя прямого віджиму розумієш все
життя коли тебе стискує воно з тебе
вижимає цей сік саме в творчості саме в
дюшах в емоціях простіше це передати
решті людей я цвітую картинки вижу ещё
во сне правда чаще дорогу зеленку и
териком ну достаточно Мига чтобы у вас
стало во мне пробуждается чутково сна
боевой Дракон у нас учили когда-то
верить прощает любить мол защиту
невинным голодного Накорми но в процессе
защиты многим Пришлось убить И теперь
нам не просто по прежнего быть людьми
щоб ти не робив нове ти створюєш який
якусь гілку ногою світу і яке б діло ти
ти наробив якщо тобі цікаво якщо
подобається розумієш навіть на війні і
це можна Ти якісь свій світ створюєш і
він живе вже завдяки
розповім і може жити вже без тебе І це
неймовірна відчуття
іду
[музика]
[оплески]
вона була Жить у воді
[музика]
залишилося зі спиртом ні хребти тільки я
кити
стансуємо вони віддам
бачу я не краще я
[музика]
це тобі
Я люблю
непомки Та й мені сили
Боже Життя моє моє
морейки успілими
критерії
[музика]
[оплески]
дуже любив займатися всім до чого
дотягнусь і чим я можу займатися не не
те що я там я схопився за це за це потім
за це не цікаво А коли ти несеш як
жонглер декілька предметів і
тримаєш у повітрі це здорово тобто я вам
займатися бізнесом в мене було музична
студія справжня звукозапис тому
займатися творчествами бізнесами міг
різним займатися так цікаво жити
розумієш
І коли ти в тебе декілька гранів і ти
можеш балансувати на них ти ніколи не
втомлюєшся В тебе є з чого нас що
перемикатися з віршів на музику з музики
зараз мені доводиться займатися і
політикою ти знаєш і багатьма е-е
багатьма речами і допомогою фронту і все
але це грані це я ось я такий тримірний
все що потрібно для добудування системи
на нових дуже чудових позиціях бачите
батальйонний комплект для 10-ї бригади
за спиною клубнику бачите
Я теж об'їдаю побратимів але привезу
замість двох ящиків
цей комплекс називається маску локи - це
веселий скандинавський Бог хитрощів Та
коварство що я можу сказати ворогу
нашому готуйтесь
рятуйтесь від цього не побачите ви цього
не будете контролювати але ви все це
відчуєте розуміти це служба
ще не згризли кістки а в горах вже тихо
заходив у двір і землю рвав на шматки
[музика]
бо поруч нікого хто встав і закрив від
лиха І ворогів бо ми полягли
А тих хто вцілів забрали у ланцюги до
контакта
та всем немного
или нет
[музика]
ішов Мольфар по полю бою
світло сльозами я як сіллю
[музика]
на полі вбиті вої
н та
брав Мольфар в долоні землю
шепотів землі я мушу
видувалку попіл темний
сумою душу
не не не не земле моя
[музика]
сил додай Мольфара жертві
м На що тобі герої
[музика]
в
там мовчить земля в долонях
вкрита сльозами як
і Мольфар у полі стогне
дід безсилля
мучениці
воїстину
кожний мов зовело себе
став між ними
на коліна
х
очі ви небо
[музика]
Це твої полеглі діти
Я ж не ти все що можу хорони
[музика]
ти
Отже наче відривають парку гуляє трубар
це пойла не сумуйко за живой парк Ми
піднялись лише хмар
щойно була
парчий погуляє туман
ой нам не сумуй козачемой парк Ми
піднялись вище хмар
щойно
[оплески]
[музика]
що я бачу кошмарах
може квести
збери по частинах братів
може те як воюю на тій стороні бачу себе
в приціл і збуваєш особливості Я танцюю
з вогнем і кулями роблю Україну бо мені
зрозуміло все в моєму сні Він вбиває
страх як заразом пеніцилін саундтреці у
нього всі знайомі пісні А під ранок
стане все як така відпав по пробудження
легко розріже душу на різних дві
і ти знаєш буває Я хочу назад в кошмар
Бо у нього принаймні шанси недольові що
я бачив кошмарах які не сняться мені чи
копаю успіх і біль чи може курю траву чи
кричу я у сні чергу прости разом
це Чого я боявся
збулося вже наяву відспівали плюс а ми
ще живі ПлюсПлюс
тепла вода початок
пекельний плюс
наша черга на чергу прокинувся
людей
із близьких друзей
где кого я знал близко на этой Войне и
все погибли за что-то не просто так не
за деньги не за Влас
А за Україну которую в 5 лет попытаемся
построить всі пазли які я носив з собою
все життя за ці роки склалося і я не
просто повірив Я знаю що правильно
розумієш кінець війни - це тоді коли моя
країна буде абсолютно вільна в своїх
картон до квадратного сантиметра окрім
пам'яті
про все це
є
відчуття
завершеної справи
Я думаю що ми
завершимо тому Україна не закінчиться
ніколи
незалежно від чинності бою Не хвилюйся
все буде як треба щоб не сталося знаєш
завжди над тобою твої діти отримують
неба Я Світанок у полі зустрінув і
пробачу
крізь ранок Бездомний Бог до сонця за
руку веде Україну
камуфляжну щасливу мадонну
Я бажаю тобі того щоб всім нам щоб скоро
був були такі часи коли все це
розсиплеться як прах і ми знову тут
будемо сидіти спілкуватися зваритися і
все буде
просто Cool і буде знову мир а вони всі
здохнуть
[оплески]
[музика]
у цьому дощі
занадто багато слів
не тримай Не питай не плач
[музика]
чужих колін
не злітає і не кидай
[музика]
Я забув твої колискові бо їх не співають
вдень а ти посміхнувшись облич щасливі
сказала досить сумних пісень
[оплески]
[музика]
сумних пісень
досить сумних пісень
[музика]